COLT MCCANDLISS:
By now, everyone
knows that APK size is
an important factor when
it comes to user acquisition.
Who wants to wait 30 minutes
to download some massive app
on a 2G connection or
pay the high data rates
required to download that
app on a metered network?
My name is Colt McCandliss.
And to keep your app from
being one of those data hogs,
there are some important
tools and tricks
that you should
keep up your sleeve.
At the [? quarter ?]
reducing APK size
comes the understanding
that bloat usually
comes from two key factors--
resources and code.
And since resources can often
account for the largest bloat,
and is the easiest to fix,
we're going to start there.
The first and most important
thing you need to do
is make sure that
you're properly
using the Remove
Unused Resources
flag in your gretl files.
This flag will remove
any content that's not
being used by your application.
This includes
anything that you've
forgotten to prune from
your tree and resources that
have been included in
third party libraries
but your app doesn't use.
Secondly, most
resource bloat comes
from supporting multiple
resolutions and screen
densities for your app.
As of Android 4.4,
the framework supports
LDPI, MDPI, TVDPI, HDPI,
xHDPI, xxHDPI, and xxxHDPI.
But let's be clear.
Just because you can
support all these densities
doesn't mean you should
have copies of your assets
for each one of them.
And see, if you
don't have resources
for a specific
resolution, the framework
will rescale an
existing resource
to fit the bill for you.
So if there is no noticeable
difference between the resource
you're scaling by hand and
the framework re-sized one,
you can toss your
custom one out.
The result is a
much leaner APK that
has only the resources it
needs for distribution.
Thirdly, we all know
that images account
for the largest footprints.
So for icons or other small,
simple graphics in your app,
you might want to take a look
at vector drawables instead
of PNGs or JPEGs.
These are assets that describe
the shape of your graphic using
XML instead of just raw pixels.
The result is that
instead of keeping around
one version of your drawable
for each supported resolution,
you instead can
use one file and it
will generate the resolution
you need at load time.
Fourthly, try to reuse
resources wherever possible.
Android provide
several utilities
to modify an existing
asset in layout code,
which you could use
to get the look you
want without having to include
a whole new unique image.
For example, let's say you've
got two images that are just
rotations of each other.
You could get rid of one by
just creating a rotate drawable
to create the other.
Now while these may
sound like small changes,
they can yield a significant
savings for your APK.
For example, the
Android framework team
was able to use
color tint support,
then go and replace nine
patches with XML shapes,
and then replace bitmaps
with vector drawables.
The result-- their APK
drawable count shrunk by 80%.
Now once you get your
assets in a smooth state,
it's now time to make
sure that your code is
as slim as possible.
See, even though
code bloat is not
as problematic as
resources, remember,
when you're downloading things
on 2G, every bit counts.
Now once again,
your first step is
to make sure that
your use of ProGuard
is being done correctly
to have code removal.
Simply set the
minified enabled flag
to True in your gretl settings.
This will signal ProGuard to
do all the heavy lifting when
you want to compile your app.
We did a video on that if
you want to learn more.
Next up, try to
optimize code which
is responsible for
generating other code.
There's lots of things, like
enums and protocol buffers,
which can result in an increased
number of methods and classes
inside of your .dex
file, thus causing bloat.
As such, make sure to have a
key nine or, in some cases,
a flame thrower, to tune and
optimize this type of code,
as it can reduce the
amount of code that
gets generated from it.
Finally, take a hard
look at libraries you've
included in your application.
Some libraries,
especially those designs
for the server or the
desktop environments,
come with a whole lot
of objects and methods
that your Android app
just doesn't need.
Now to be fair, ProGuard helps
solve part of this problem.
But it can't fix everything
since some of these libraries
can have big internal
dependencies that ProGuard just
can't remove.
Not to mention that for
these large libraries,
this type of
ProGuard optimization
can come at a great cost of
taking longer to compile.
As such, always make
sure to try to find
a tiny, mobile friendly,
alternative version
of the library you need.
And if that fails,
you can always
just extract the functions
you need from the library
and put in your own code base
if you're willing to do that.
Anyhow, the most
important in all of this
is properly splitting your APK.
See, there's some content that
is bundled into your APK which
all users have to download,
but only some [? SOA ?] portion
will ever use, like
having a small screen
device download a high
resolution screen content.
To fix this, the
Android platform
allows you to split
content into different APKs
based on things like APK levels,
screen sizes, and GPU texture
support.
This way, devices with
specific screen sizes
won't receive assets
from sizes it won't use.
Although, be warned
that this does
come with a little extra
overhead to build and deploy.
Oh, and as of
Android Studio 2.2,
there's a really
fancy new built in APK
analyzer, which
helps you understand
the contents and the sizes
of different components
in your APK.
It gives you direct access
to see what's being included,
its sizes, and help
you figure out what's
needed to make them smaller.
See, at its core,
making smaller APKs
makes faster downloads, which
makes happier users, which
makes happier developers.
So make everybody
happier by checking out
the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns videos.
And don't forget to ask the
tough questions on our Google+
community.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]